I've never been much for smoking
But taking a bullet to your chest
Will make you a lot less worried
About the slow deaths of the world
Long story short I took a job I shouldn't have
They say the pretty ones will always get you killed
But he was so damn handsome I couldn't resist
I was a frog in a slow pot of boiling water
I was the first clown to get into the clown car
You don't know to get out until it's too late
One thing led to another
And I found myself slow dancing with the devil in the moonlight
Except instead of leaving room for Jesus,
He left room for a 357 magnum
I won't bore you with the details
So I'll cut right to the quick
A lot of people died because of this man
William J. Barnum
a.k.a. The Colonel
Just like the clown at my bar mitzvah
I knew he was trouble from the moment I laid eyes on him
And just like Bozo The Magnificent
A lot of people died when he walked into my life
*Mark giggling*
A lot of people died when he wa—
*clears throat*
I've been chasing him down ever since
We were like two naked men running on the same treadmill.
Uncomfortably close
But always just a step behind
But no one can run forever
Especially not with 200 pounds of sweaty detective breathing down your neck
It hasn't been easy though
I can't count how many countries I've cornered him in
Couldn't tell you how many times I've had him in my big, strong hands
Every time I think I've got him for good
He somehow manages to slip away
But he's running out of holes to hide in
I mean that literally, metaphorically, and euphemistically
It doesn't matter how crafty you think you are
If you've been on the run for years and years
Eventually
You're gonna make a mistake
Word of advice:
If you're running away from your problems, never become to attached to anything
Families, lovers, briefcases on top of your car.
Some things are best left behind
The Colonel is a slippery one
Shedding names as easily as a snake sheds a few pounds before bikini season
He's going through pseudonym after pseudonym trying to cover his tracks
But he always manages to fall back into the same familiar ways
Drinking, fighting, flirting
Dancing
SUBSCRIBE TO MARKIPLIER!